peinture sculpture photographie une
sélection d'oeuvres différentes à
découvrir à la salle d'exposition à
guyancourt leur point commun elles se
sont toutes des oeuvres d'artistes du
territoire choisi par un jury de
professionnels art à l'enm est à
l'honneur les talents locaux découverte
avec camille lambert et nicolas landry
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose d'un peu
apocalyptique où les gens les routes
vont nulle part j'avais envie d'un peu
d'exprimer sa une société où il reste
quelques éléments de marketing avec des
marques qui sont un peu me présente vous
tout est un peu ça le tout est un peu
délavé
comme s'ils s'étaient passé quelque
chose mais les gens continuent leur vie
dans cette ville c'est un petit peu ce
que je voulais présenter avec beaucoup
d'influencé bien sûr de science fiction
de films futuristes de divers dystopie
d'où le nom de l'oeuvre dystopia une
ville futuriste créé à partir de cartons
de circuits imprimés ou de plastique un
univers foisonnant imaginé par kg sommes
plusieurs mois de travail pour cet
habitant de guyancourt avec art talent
la vie lui donne l'opportunité d'exposer
avec d'autres artistes du territoire
c'est notre troisième édition c'est un
concours d'art en direction des artistes
locaux professionnels et bien sûr
amateurs c'est vraiment divers
complètement toutes les esthétiques donc
à de la sculpture la peinture la
photographie un mélange de techniques et
d'émotion des paysages épurés du désert
de l'invité d'honneur francis tac aux
créatures surréalistes d'arnaud shoot
c'est chamlal c'est une
photo fait à la base de farine qui
ensuite sur un portrait farine je le met
en mode miroir et on obtient une ce que
j'appelle des bestioles
je veux que chacun puisse partir un
petit peu là où il a envie d'aller avec
cette bestiole la deûle imaginé quelque
part on l'imaginé juste de l'imaginer
savoir ce qu'elle représente une
sélection d'oeuvres à découvrir jusqu'au
29 avril
différents ateliers rencontres avec les
artistes sont prévues tout le mois